tu m'appelles lauriane j'ai 9 ans et
j'habite à laval maple un geste histoire
et elle habite à 4 je m'appelle aimerait
j'ai 8 ans et j'habite pas seulement sur
le lac
il y avait plein de police l'armée les
pompiers avaient les sirènes partout il
fallait évacuer
parce qu'il ya l'eau était comme support
preuve de la maison et que de la route
allait y avoir que lors d'un il est rue
il fallait bien être des sacs de sable
aux a monté presque jusqu'au garage pie
ix ou si un peu dans les marches
je t'ai stressé oui je tremblais des
jambes bien l'art mais là c'est pas
pourrir mon pari étaient compressés ma
belle marque aussi mais sont est comme
en train de courir pour chercher le
stock
c'est le seul on avait boucher tous les
trous l'année passée par les moeurs sauf
que sa ressortie par dole le dreg la
douche puis dans le pipeline flaques
d'eau c'est le salon rempli de jouets
qu'une rame suppose de temps parce que y
avait des inondations il y avait de la
pluie de la loi montech j'avais par le
père de la maison à l'école en premier
il fallait aller en chaloupe 1 2 sel il
fallait pas un bug du bateau est en 3e
et 4e bars créé y avait trop d'où on la
voit qu'ils les kayaks de mon voisin
était toujours de l'autre bord de la rue
alors on pouvait traverser un kayak je
disais c'est drôle
mais tant qu'à y à qui j'allais le
poteau 22e marc accos que moi je ne
pouvais pas marcher avec
on était à l'hôtel laval peu vu que vu
que la croix rouge je savais pas où nous
place et on a été ouvert et à laval si
tom un petit peu ennuyant mais comme
c'était cool que y avait une ex boxeur
bodin restaurant vue cloud avait trop
monté on est due à habiter chez ma grand
mère pendant toujours pis je me sentais
bizarre parce que j'aime
j'aurais aimé retourner chez moi quand
je te rentrer la première fois ma maison
il y avait un gros tas de poubelles son
bord de ma maison de tous les débris
tellement beau que c'était plus bon
comme nous je des landes du les
stylistes un plâtre quand j'ai vu le
sous sol je voyais tout les membres
arrachés une salle de bains et puis de
foyers plus de vue des sky et plus rien
je t'aime 10 pouces triste parce que
montants dépassent ceux ci quand y avait
plus doux dans la rue ils me sentait
soulagé parce qu'il y avait plus doux
dans la file pilou avait baissé savent
plus quelle année prochaine en ayant
comme une non dation puis j'y parle pour
l'année prochaine mais je m'inquiète
comme kial encore la diekirch gosse
qu'on doit être évacuée et qu'un genre
stress parce que j'aime beaucoup comme
ce pc merci de m'avoir écouté